hey it's Friday again time for another
movie retrospective today we're doing
one that I've been wanting to do since
we started thinking about doing this
move your introspection in the first
place because this is one of my very
very favorite movies in the 1970s this
is don't look now from 1973 kind of an I
don't know if I'd call it underrated
because it's pretty critically loved and
it usually turns up like on a lot of
best horror movies of the 70s lists but
it feels like one that maybe a lot of
younger horror fans haven't seen yeah
I've never seen it
Janny showed it to me for the first time
and it was a good movie but I don't
really know it as well as she does so
we're just gonna let her roll with this
it was a pretty good movie though yeah
this was actually based on a story by
Daphne du Maurier who very famously
wrote a couple she's probably most
famous for doing stuff that Alfred
Hitchcock did she wrote the birds and
Rebecca which Alfred Hitchcock
obviously you know made into movies
later on so this is based on a story of
hers it's fairly you know it's fairly
kind of like the source material but not
exactly
it's basically Donald Sutherland is in
it and Julie Christie plays his wife and
it's kind of like it was directed by
Nicolas ruing brag about that who also
did performance man who fell to earth
you know movies like that so he's kind
of a very I don't want to call him like
an idiosyncratic filmmaker but he does
he definitely has a distinctive visual
style and distinctive like way of doing
things particular way of editing and
stuff and he uses like a lot of it's not
so much straightforward plot but he
likes to use like a lot of thematic
elements that kind of repeat and stuff
like that so the movie was shot
beautifully it is looking at the it's a
pretty movie yeah it really is
and it's kind of like it's it's a
symbolic film in the sense that it's
about grief over the death of a child
but then there's like kind of all this
other stuff going on - like I said
Donald Sutherland is in it and Julie
Christie they play like a
a wife the Baxters and their daughter
Christine drowns accidentally in you
know a pond on their property and then
some sort of undetermined amount of time
later you see that they've gone to
Venice presumably to get over their
grief about it Donald Sutherland
character plays he's like an art
restorer so he's overseeing the
restoration of this you know Cathedral
in Venice so that's why they've gone
there he accepted this job kind of to
get away from the home since they could
forget about it now the interesting
thing about Donald Sutherland character
is that we see from the very beginning
when the daughter Christine drowns he
has a premonition I mean hit him and his
wife were inside the house they're
talking about something else and you
know Christine is outside playing and
she falls in and drowns and he
immediately knows that something is
wrong and he runs outside but it's too
late to save her she's already drowned
so we're establishing at the beginning
that Donald Sutherland has psychic
powers however he's like in denial about
them yeah they have permissions and
visions and [ __ ] right so he's almost
like it's almost like he's been gifted
this I guess and but he's like denying
the kitchen I feel like he doesn't want
to know I actually thought that was kind
of a realistic portrayal of psychic
abilities which really kind of you know
that's very 70s very 70s and 80 yeah
that's usually how it was portrayed in
like paranormal literature yeah about
about the you know in Paris
psychological literature so in that way
again and kind of give a star for
credibility yeah yeah and well you buy
it also because he's such a skeptic he
comes across as very dismissive of
anything having to do with psychic
powers anything having to do with
religion anything like that whereas his
wife seems a little more open-minded now
after they look at there's got a catch
she hid she makes like a little worse
yes she always makes noises like that
she doesn't meow that much she just
makes that what she feels is she's being
nord yeah she's like you guys what are
you doing why are you not putting me
right now okay yeah so um so when they
first go to Venice like I don't know how
long they've been there I'm assuming it
hasn't been long they're in a restaurant
and the wife Julie Christie she notices
that like these two women are like
looking at her and it's kind of freaking
her out a little bit and then they have
some kind of thing where they have to go
in the bathroom and it looks like one of
them is kind of like you know
handicapped or something so she goes in
there to help them now one of the women
is blind and kind of freaky looking it
must be said now she says to Julie
Christie's character that oh I see your
daughter she's sitting in between you
and she describes the red raincoat that
Christine was wearing when she drowned
so at this point it's funny because
Julie Christie's totally buys into it
she's like oh my god like pretty much
that's all the information she has to go
on oh she's wearing a red raincoat she's
laughing you know she's happy now she I
could see her in between you two
everything's okay and so Julie Christie
is like oh and she almost has like um it
makes her she like accepts the death
more because she's like oh well she's
still here and she's still around and
she still loves us and everything's
awesome which in some ways like Donald
Sutherland characters kind of conflicted
about this because you know yes he's
glad to have his wife back like there's
a very extended very famous rather
graphic for the time sex scene which is
kind of establishing because you're
meant to imply that they haven't had sex
in a long time since their daughter died
and they you know she has had a hard
time getting over it so there's this
kind of like reconnection between them
and so he's happy about that but then on
the other hand she sort of gets obsessed
with this idea that these two women or
this blind woman who was says she's a
psychic can see her daughter and so
Donald Sutherland is kind of like well I
feel like she's getting you know sucked
into this with these two women and it's
you know maybe it's not healthy for her
because he doesn't believe it obviously
even though he has psychic powers
himself
like I said he's in denial about it now
while this [ __ ] is all going on - there
is also the small matter of a serial
killer running around Venice now this is
actually interesting because it's almost
like it's I feel like a lot of movies
would have this be the main thrust of
the story but this is not the main
thrust of the story pretty much they're
their you know relationship there
you know her relationship with the two
psychic women that's kind of like the
main meet of the movie but then like on
the outside you have this serial killing
every now and then like they'll be going
down a canal like in a boat and they'll
see like there's crime-scene tape or
they're pulling a body out of the canal
or something like that and there's kind
of [ __ ] about you know the serial killer
running around so then like all this the
thing about this movie - is that this is
definitely not like I said a
straightforward type of film it's it's
kind of a lot of atmosphere and the way
Nicolas Roeg does his movies is that he
likes to play with timelines and
especially this one because it's about
psychic abilities about precognition you
know and also the past coming back to
haunt you and stuff like that so he
doesn't make a distinction between the
past the present and the future so
sometimes when you see something like
very famously there's a very famous
scene where Donald southern only is on a
boat and he thinks that his wife has
gone back to England you know to care
for their son who is you know was hurt
in a fall like back at his boarding
school and then later that day after she
supposedly left on a plane he sees her
but like on a funeral boat and she has
like all the grieving clothes and she's
like on the boat with the two women and
he's like flipping out about it now the
interesting thing about this is that the
whole the way the whole thing goes and I
don't want to like spoil it too much
because I know probably a lot of people
I mean probably people my age get horror
fans have seen it but I feel like maybe
a lot of younger people haven't it has
to do with self-fulfilling prophecy
because he has a vision that he doesn't
realize his a vision and the fact that
he has that vision makes the bad [ __ ] in
the vision
come true you know I mean so it's like a
self-fulfilled so it's like a endless
loop like I'm like a mobius strip so I
think that's kind of cool the way they
did that with the movie and I have to
say that like I said there's a lot of
kind of repeated aspects of this like
the color red they wanted to wash
everything out and make everything like
kind of like brown or beige in the movie
like I said it's Venice so you know
everything's like stone so then when you
see flashbacks with Christine's red
raincoat you see the serial killer who
has also has a red coat which at first
you kind of think it's a ghost like of
Christine but it's like a different coat
but it's red you know Julie Christie has
like these bright red boots or like a
bright red purse so there's red there's
like a lot of water references like
anytime something Bad's gonna happen
glass breaks there's a lot of references
to like falling or getting hurt in the
fall there's like a lot of that kind of
stuff going on too so as I said it's not
so much like a straightforward narrative
as it is kind of like I don't know like
a symbolic you know sort of thing about
like I said about grief about you know
the psychic thing like being a loop and
like coming around and making things
happen that maybe wouldn't have happened
as a person has really only seen it once
and recently you know is the first time
I've ever seen it was well how long ago
is if we watch it was probably like a
week ago the movie was a slow burner it
is yeah I would say it I like those
along the lines of maybe like The
Changeling
yeah kinda if you guys have ever seen
the movie The Changeling but we did a
review on but it's it had a very Italian
look and feel to it but high quality not
so much giallo it didn't feel like a
giallo movie you know like a higher
version like a like a very expensive
Italian movie it had a European flavor
and look to it to me the way the style
was it wasn't an action movie it's an
art flick forces more like an art flick
I don't want to say that this is a chick
flick but I could really see how this
movie
would have a lot of appeal to women
because it is for people that are really
paying attention to other people it's
not an action movie yes it's not a bro
movie no okay
not buy anything you know I'm kind of
I'm a little bit of a caveman I like but
I still I still appreciated the movie
for what it was it's not necessarily my
kind of movie but I'm gonna go ahead and
give it my approval
yeah it is a very high quality room I
wouldn't call like I said like you said
and um it usually gets lumped in with
with the changeling with movies like
that yes man like that we should say
shudder the reason I'm doing this
now finally cuz I don't have it on DVD
sadly is because shudder just added this
and they added the changeling likes just
a couple weeks ago now that you mention
shudder we don't spot a sponsor shedder
isn't sponsoring us we're not plugging
for shall we just like it but I tell you
what we should we should shot her all
right we're gonna call shudders thank
you so much you have to break us off
shudder yeah no no that's the thing
that's like they add good [ __ ] all the
time and is so excited when I saw they
if shudder ever becomes our sponsor all
right if we were to say that all right
I've got one a longtime listeners to
know that even before they were our
sponsor we lights shutter
dude it's five bucks five bucks a month
it's like why a lot of babies well like
a quarter the cost of Netflix I mean I
like Netflix too if like for more
general movies and they have some decent
horror movies too but if you if you're
into horror and sci-fi and thrillers and
[ __ ] like that I mean five bucks a
multicam yeah I actually prefer shudder
over Netflix I watched a couple things
on Netflix and I liked but you know I
liked I liked just like the Punisher
series damn st yeah the new MSC that's
kind of why we kept it more for
blackberry series yeah black for more TV
series lost in space has got my good
friend parker posey on it and grew up we
came up together
so but the rest of the stuff like the
movies on netflix they don't have very
many the old class they don't have yet
they have a lot of good new ones nothing
old but not a lot of classics your i
noticed the other day speaking of
netflix it
I had added some from the 90s like they
added like I know what she did last
summer eight like it freaks right um a
couple of those type of movies which
that's good so they might be feeling the
heat from shutter and it's like well we
need to add some other [ __ ] on shutter
you can go back and watch all of the old
Halloween's one two three four five six
now it's one it has one one one four and
five one four and five one four five
they I think they think they had some
old Friday 13th didn't they
I don't know about Friday the 13th they
have a bunch of it's just a lot of a
bunch of phantasms yes four five they
had some of the hellraisers they had
[ __ ] what was the thing they see like
what wolf cop what was that one yeah you
know just like they have a lot of they
have a lot of jell-o movies yet a lot of
Dario Argento 70s and 80s classics
Sampada Lucio folce they have the Beyond
house by the cemetery City the Living
Dead they just added the other day and
ease on it
yeah so it's and I think beyond put the
black rainbows on there too or that
might be an applicant really done but I
was like I said the reason that I wanted
to do Don't Look Now is because this is
one of the first movies that I wrote
down when we first started making a list
for our movie retrospective and I was
like okay but I don't have it so I
haven't done it yet and so the other day
I think didn't I actually when I opened
up shutter and they had just added it
that day I think I might have screamed
but um so they added that at the end of
the changeling so I was like super I was
like well we already did one on the
changing changeling but I have to do
don't look now because like I said this
is one of my the 70s everybody knows if
you you know follow the show at all or
if you read it in my youtube comments
the 70s is my very favorite era for baby
married yeah
yeah we did one on that too yeah like I
said what's it and we saw that and death
line two or raw meat which was the same
director we did that as a joke sure
yeah they got chewed the stuff q.q the
wing it's urban yeah they just said good
ones and bad you sucked but it was it's
you know it's I liked them ponder why I
like Lehrer
I like there we go I told me to for five
bucks a month shedders offering good
[ __ ] so yeah they have like I said they
it's curated very well they have like a
good combo of like old there was a free
one we were
chin and we threw that one down because
we couldn't give couldn't get a reliable
stream on it and the selection wasn't
that good well is that free TV I watch
it I watch that sometimes yeah I can
watch it on my laptop it's before five
bucks a month you get just totally downs
to be I finally finally on to be you
guys I finally watched the cabin in the
woods isn't it bad that I haven't seen
it I hadn't seen it until now it's like
I felt like such a bad horror nerd
because it's like one of the big movies
of the 2000s and I'm like oh my god I
really have to get around to watching
cabin in the woods and it was amazing I
was like I can't believe I didn't see it
but I saw that on TV but uh yeah so if
you have a shudder don't look now is on
there um you should really check it out
like I said the 70s my favorite era for
horror it's a it's a very slow bird it's
very arty it's not don't go into it
expecting like traditional like you know
three-part story like arc you know like
a normal kind of story arc not an action
movie it's kind of more you really
really have to pay attention to
everyone's conversations you have to pay
attention to where you are in the
timeline you know what I mean because
like I said he kind of plays with it a
little bit you don't really know if what
you're seeing happened already or it
hasn't happened already so there's kind
of that whole thing and honestly the
last scene of this the final scene where
I'm not gonna spoil it but where Donald
Sutherland like meets the hooded figure
that's a pretty awesome creepy scene
because when that person first my cell
that I was like it's like really really
creepy and I think that actually ended
up on the Bravo's like top one there's
like scariest movie moments or something
like that but mention a show know what
else is cool about shudder what John
Carpenter did the theme to shudder
theme song to the service and like I
said they don't sponsor us we just like
it
yeah and they gonna sponsor so you owe
me some money I just wanna show he's
this what's a shirt
he has simple tasty is simple taste but
yeah so if you haven't seen don't look
down maybe I know a lot of the other
people haven't go check it out
especially if you like you know art
house flicks are like you know
these movies cuz I really really like
this one a lot and I feel like it
doesn't get a lot of love from the
younger horror community so go check it
out and that will do it for our latest
movie retrospective remember if you like
the show to like share subscribe on all
your social media if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page which is a patreon
common the clock podcast or you can go
to our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
dot wordpress.com and there's a link in
the sidebar to a PayPal account
remember our movie retrospectives just
like this one right here come out every
Friday we also have 13 o'clock matinee
which is three new movies in the theatre
and that comes up every Sunday and our
regular episodes come in every Tuesday
so check them all out we will see you
next time bye